[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend wenn sich die großen der
welt treffen dann geht es meist wenig
und konkrete maßnahmen aber immer um
symbole und signale so war das auch
heute beim g20 treffen der wichtigsten
industrie und schwellenländer in rom
corona war das hauptthema und das
symbolbild dazu bei dieses zum
sogenannten familienfoto versammelten
sich die staats und regierungschefs
nicht allein sondern holten pflegekräfte
ärzte innen und sanitäter dazu
anerkennung für harte arbeit in der
pandemie mehr impfstoff für ärmere
länder
da blieb es bislang bei appellen
angela merkel absolvierte den tag im
duett mit olaf scholz amtsübergabe auf
internationaler bühne inklusive
vorstellung beim us-präsidenten aus rom
matthäus
als der abend kam in rom gab es beim
gipfel kultur mit symbolcharakter
wie man raus streit
zurückfindet zur gemeinsamkeit aber
beginnen wir von vorne hauch von pomp
auch schon am morgen und der anschein
von lässigkeit bei ihrem wohl
allerletzten gipfel hat ganze lehre
repubblica ferrari die germania stadt la
concha jerez beim nächsten mal will kann
chili er heißen und der potenzielle neue
trat heute schon gewissermaßen in ihre
fußstapfen vielleicht deshalb wirkte
angela merkel tatsächlich ungewöhnlich
lässig auch als josi herzlich umarmte
wertschätzung vom amerikanischen
präsidenten
und dann machten alle ein wenig platz
für noch mehr wertschätzung ein signal
der solidarität
jedenfalls mit denen die an vorderster
front ihr leben wagen im kampf gegen
korona aber die solidarität mit ärmeren
ländern in denen bisher nur drei prozent
der menschen geimpft sind weitgehend auf
dem niveau von absichtserklärungen
immerhin gibt es erste verträge mit
ruanda und senegal für die produktion
von impfstoff in afrika die notwendige
technologie soll weitergegeben werden
eine einigung gab es auch bei der
globalen mindeststeuer von 15 prozent
pandemic von der pandemie über den
klimawandel bis zu einer fairen und
gleichwertigen besteuerung sind
alleingänge einfach keine lösung simple
badelatschen dem würden sogar sie
zustimmen aber die demonstranten glauben
den politikern ihre worte nicht solange
ihnen nicht mehr taten folgen auch im
kampf gegen den klimawandel
die einst in paris vereinbarten ziele
unerreichbar denn die nur nichts
überstürzen
signalisiert zugeschaltet auch der
russische präsident
russland schlägt eine gehaltvolle
diskussion in dieser sache vor
pragmatisch im ton ausschließlich
basierend auf wirtschaftlichen
erwägungen
gegen die bremser könnten diese 24 23 am
sonntag beim thema klima gemeinsam druck
machen joe biden weiß genau dass die
mögliche kanzlerschaft von olaf scholz
auch von den grünen abhängt die wie der
us präsident eine transformation der
gesellschaft fordern im kampf gegen die
erderwärmung beim heiklen thema iran saß
scholz schon fast mit am tisch denn es
könnte schneller eskalieren als erwartet
die anreicherung werden im iran
fortgesetzt das beunruhigt uns sehr und
deshalb jahreszeit darüber zu sprechen
was man tun kann damit die bewaffnung
des iran mit waffen nicht stattfindet
den ernst der welt mal kurz zurücklassen
das konnten angela merkel ihr mann
joachim sauer und all die anderen am
ende dieses tages beim letzten gipfel
dinner mit lacken jazeera
und den gipfel in rom verfolgt und
alabama dem ich konnte leider gibt es
heute abend die meldungen dass der
streit zwischen europa und den usa um
die strafzölle auf stahl und aluminium
beigelegt wurde ist das die neue
harmonie in nachtrandzeiten
ja das kann man sicherlich so werten
diese strafzölle haben hier die
europäisch-amerikanischen beziehungen
seit circa drei jahren schwer belastet
und die eu ist dem vernehmen nach auch
in den vergangenen wochen schon in
gesprächen gewesen mit washington aber
es ist sicherlich kein zufall dass es
dass die nachricht gerade jetzt an
diesem gipfel wochenende kommt es passt
einfach zu gut in die reihe von gesten
die joe biden hier beim gipfel und rund
um den gipfel gesetzt hat um zu
signalisieren die usa sind zurück im
multilateralen verhandlungstisch und
diese spezielle geste die kostet joe
biden auch etwas denn zu hause ist die
heimische stahlindustrie mit diesem
schritt nicht sehr zufrieden
morgen ist nun der klimaschutz das
hauptthema danach machen sich ja viele
der gipfelteilnehmer auf nach glasgow
zur weltklimakonferenz was ist denn nun
das signal von gipfel zu gipfel in
sachen klima besonders kraftvoll scheint
das nicht auszufallen oder
mit letzter sicherheit kann man das
heute noch nicht sagen denn
überraschungen sind natürlich bei
solchen gipfel nie vollständig
ausgeschlossen aber tatsächlich hören
wir dass zum beispiel eine verschärfung
der klimaschutzziele hier auf diesem
gipfel unwahrscheinlich ist das wäre ein
starkes zeichen von den 20 nationen die
immerhin für 80 prozent der weltweiten
treibhausgasemissionen zuständig sind
so weit wird es hier wahrscheinlich
nicht kommen wenn es so kommt wie wir es
so aus verhandlungskreisen hörte
heraushören können dann wird es eher ein
signal werden auch hier wieder die
bedeutung der usa sie sind zurück sie
sitzen wieder mit am tisch nach einer
ära in der tram gesagt hat klimaschutz
ist für uns nicht das wichtigste thema
und das planen wir auch nicht
multilateral da könnte eine neue dynamik
daraus entstehen aber für diesen gipfel
könnte am ende gelten es werden
weiterhin erst einmal
absichtserklärungen dankeschön chuck und
alanya merkel nimmt abschied auf
internationaler bühne in das kleinklein
der parteipolitik will sie sich nicht
mehr einmischen die zukunft der cdu
werde jetzt durch andere bestimmt sagte
reh in einem faz interview wer in
zukunft als nachfolger von armin laschet
an der spitze stehen wird ist weiter
unklar klar ist seit heute aber wie
derjenige ermittelt werden soll in einer
mitgliederbefragung
die kreis und bezirksvorsitzenden der
cdu sprachen sich mit großer mehrheit
dafür aus und so wird es nun auch kommen
fehlen nur noch die kandidat matthias
vetter
als der cdu generalsekretär nach der
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz vor den
kameras steht schwärmt er nahezu ein tag
des aufbruchs des neuanfangs sei heute
da wäre es eigentlich nicht wirklich was
passiert
die cdu sucht immer noch einen
vorsitzenden und übt sich dafür in
basisdemokratie der nächste vorsitzende
oder die nächste vorsitzende der cdu
deutschlands soll ermittelt werden unter
durchführung einer mitgliederbefragung
die überwiegende mehrheit bei den
kreisvorsitzenden spiegelt die stimmung
bei den mitgliedern hockenheim in baden
württemberg gestern abend das täte gut
daran wenn man der basis mehr gewicht
geben die unzufriedenheit war zu groß
dass doch eine basisabstimmung wichtiges
auch 500 kilometer weiter östlich in
dresden das selbe bild dieselbe stimmung
bei der cdu basis hat die eigene führung
massiv an vertrauen verloren der
mitgliederentscheid soll verlorenes
zurückbringen
das muss ich jetzt mal was ändern von
der basis her sonst kriegt man die
bevölkerung nie abgeholt schon am morgen
sah sich die parteiführung mit dieser
forderung konfrontiert als
kreisvorsitzender aus thüringen genau
dafür vor der cdu konferenz
demonstrierten ein ziemlich einmaliger
vorgang
generalsekretär zehn jahre alt da schon
dass er diesen verfahren nicht entkommen
kann jetzt tickt die uhr für die
nachfolge von armin laschet am dienstag
entscheidet der cdu parteivorstand über
den zeitplan mögliche kandidaten müssen
jetzt aus der deckung wir kennen doch
den einen oder anderen der vielleicht
mit dem gedanken spielt zu kandidieren
und wir verlassen uns auf alle wenn es
dann zu einer mitgliederbefragung kommt
dass dieses votum dann auch akzeptiert
und respektiert wird ein klarer hinweis
und friedrich merz jens spahn ralph
brinkhaus carsten linnemann und norbert
röttgen jetzt aufzuhören mit dem
taktieren fünf männer halle 5 aus nrw
alle fünf zählern nur zu einer einigung
sind sie bisher nicht in der lage
brinkhaus und röttgen gelten eher als
einzelkämpfer märz würde zwar als
vorsitzender kandidieren aber sich nicht
einsortieren und sparen und lindemann
gelten zwar als kompatibel aber alleine
auch zu schwach darum muss es jetzt
gehen bei den kandidaten nicht um einen
wettbewerb zwischen den personen sondern
ein wettbewerb um die besten ideen die
verteilt eine große erwartung an die die
der parteivorsitzende werden möchten
nämlich dass im team gebildet wird dass
eine mannschaft sich präsentiert und
damit auch kampfkandidaturen der partei
nicht erneut zugemutet werden ab
dienstag werden bewerbungen erwartet als
mannschaft oder als einzelkämpfer der
cdu stehen noch turbulente wochen bevor
und nun zunächst nachrichten mit kunde
der pause
die nasa hat den für morgen früh
geplanten flug des deutschen astronauten
matthias maurer zur internationalen
raumstation verschoben ein herr
anziehendes sturmtief mache den start in
cape canaveral zu gefährlich jetzt soll
es am mittwoch um kurz nach sechs uhr
morgens unserer zeit losgehen zugleich
hat ein unbemannter russischer
raumfrachter inzwischen die iss erreicht
er brachte neben treibstoff und
verpflegung auch schon
weihnachtsgeschenke für die besatzung
ins all
im sudan sind bei massenprotesten gegen
die militärmachthaber mindestens drei
menschen getötet worden pro
demokratische gruppen in dem
nordostafrikanischen land hatten zu
einem nationalen tag des widerstandes
aufgerufen sicherheitskräfte waren im
einsatz unklar warum sie scharfe
munition einsetzten der militärputsch am
vergangenen montag hatte international
protest und empörung ausgelöst
die kanaren insel la palma ist vom
stärksten erdbeben seit dem
vulkanausbruch erschüttert worden
täglich gibt es dutzende erdbeben auf
der atlantikinsel der vulkan war am 19
september erstmals nach 50 jahren wieder
ausgebrochen seither strömt lava aus und
hat mittlerweile
2500 gebäude zerstört auf einer fläche
von knapp
950 hektar
nach kritik der ärzteschaft an dem
appell von bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen für auffrischungsimpfungen gegen
korona heißt es heute aus seinem
ministerium grundsätzlich hätten alle
bürger anspruch auf eine booster impfung
ärztepräsident reinhard befürwortet
dagegen tritt impfungen für über
70-jährige vor erkrankte sowie
beschäftigte von kliniken senioren und
pflegeheimen er warnte zugleich vor
erneuten notlagen in den kliniken
die warnungen werden eindringlicher und
es ist offensichtlich dass die vierte
welle rollt die korona zahlen steigen
weiter sprunghaft an
21.500 43 neue fälle meldet das rk ii
das sind 6000
398 mehr als vergangenen samstag 90
weitere menschen starben im zusammenhang
mit dem virus auch die inzidenz geht
deutlich nach oben
145,1
vollständig geimpft sind hierzulande gut
zwei drittel der menschen über zwölf
jahren das genügt nicht für entwarnung
in russland und dann schauen wir jetzt
ist es gerade mal gut ein drittel das
land erlebt die vierte welle
katastrophal rekordwerte an
neuinfektionen und todesfällen der kreml
reagiert erst jetzt mit logos und
zwangsurlaub für begangen
elenas vater starb ankurbelt die russin
wendet sich an einen lokalen
fernsehsender
weil sie erschüttert was sie sieht als
sie um die freigabe seiner leiche kämpft
kein platz für die toten auch für die
mitarbeiter innen der pathologie von
ivanova schwer zu verkraften
einer unserer pfleger wurde ohnmächtig
und wir mussten mit begrenzten kräften
darunter auch mit den frauen die
leichensäcke umladen der anblick ist
natürlich nicht schön der bekommt man
gänsehaut
libri.de
einigen regionen russlands fehlt es an
krankenwagen besatzungen anderen an
sauerstoff und überall vermelden sie die
pandemie verjüngt ihr gesicht mehr
kleinkinder mehr säuglinge werden
eingeliefert russland gegen die del
tabelle nicht nur in diesem krankenhaus
sechs autostunden von moskau entfernt
empfinden sie es als krieg und nico
schon in friedenszeiten hat unser
krankenhaus 4 130 betten jetzt sind es
800 dafür haben wir ein paar abteilungen
reduziert die wir nicht brauchen in
friedenszeiten öffnen wir sie wieder
nur ein drittel der bevölkerung ist
geimpft dabei werden vier präparate
kostenlos angeboten alle aus heimischer
entwicklung keine von wh oder immer
anerkannt bei g20 wirkt la die mir putin
heute wir schlagen vor die
gesundheitsministerien der g20 staaten
zu beauftragen sich zeitnah mit der
frage der gegenseitigen anerkennung
nationaler im zertifikate zu befassen
über 1000 tote pro tag seit wochen fast
täglich neue rekordzahlen bei der
anstieg dagegen sollen jetzt landesweite
corona ferien helfen 7 arbeitsfreie tage
die viele zum reisen nutzen
infektionsketten werden so er nicht
gebrochen diese freiwilligen bereiten
sich in moskau auf ihren einsatz auf
kurz stationen vor schwer kranke
patienten wickeln waschen füttern
während viele ihrer landsleute corona
weiter ignorieren
wenn ich das erlebe bin ich manchmal
gereicht manchmal wütend manchmal tut es
mir leid aber gleichzeitig verstehe ich
dass der mensch frei ist und selbst
entscheiden
wo das regime stetig freiheiten raubt
mit rebellion gegen die masken pflicht
überführt wo zu oft gelogen wurde fehlt
das vertrauen erklären viele den preis
für die tiefen gräben zwischen regierung
und volk zahlen die russinnen in der
pandemie mit ihrer gesundheit und zu oft
auch mit ihrem leben
heute nacht also wird die uhr wieder
eine stunde bei uns zurückgestellt auf
normalzeit auch winterzeit genannt das
heißt eine stunde mehr schlaf das
europaparlament hatte 2009 10 zwar
beschlossen die halbjährliche
zeitumstellung abzuschaffen
die mitgliedstaaten aber können sich
nicht einigen ob künftig sommer oder
winterzeit gelten sollen
eines ist sicher samstags gibt es immer
frische lottozahlen sie lauten ohne
gewähr 6 11 15 31 42 45 superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 das
wetter morgen am reformationstag wird
herbstlich bewölkt soll ich würde es nur
von der ostsee bis bayern sonst bleibt
es bei einem mix aus sonne und vielen
wolken meist trocken zum abend kommt im
westen regen auf bei milden 13 bis 20
grad mit dem start in den november wird
es deutlich wechselhafter regenschauer
viele wolken und deutlich kühlere
temperaturen
und dann geben wir sie jetzt sofort
weiter ins sportstudio mit jochen breyer
einen schönen sonntag
bis morgen
[Musik]